Let’s talk about Venezuela
and why it has two
competing presidents.
Juan Guaido is the
one recognised by
dozens of countries.
But Nicolas Maduro is
the one in charge.
In parliament the opposition parties hold a majority.
But elections are coming up
and the opposition is split over whether to boycott them.
And while the
politicians argue
people in Venezuela are struggling more than ever.
So if things are so bad why does Maduro still hold power?
What could happen
if the opposition
decides to sit out
the elections?
And why aren’t there big protests anymore?
For years we’ve been watching Venezuela climb to the top
of just about every
awful index there is.
Worst economy
in the world
the highest murder rate
and a refugee crisis that
rivals the one in Syria.
That’s down to a combination of bad economic policy
corruption
and in the last two
years — sanctions.
And this is how hard it is for people to feed themselves.
Hyperinflation has made Venezuela’s currency
the bolivar, almost
worthless.
The minimum wage is 1.2 million bolivars a month.
That’s just over a dollar.
At that rate you’d have to work two months
to buy a carton of eggs.
And prices go up
every week.
It’s a mess.
But it wasn’t
always this bad.
Venezuela was once the place to be in Latin America.
Its huge oil reserves helped build a booming economy.
But over time corruption
and inequality grew
and the shine started
to wear off.
Enter President
Hugo Chavez.
His social programmes
were popular
but they relied on
taking over businesses
controlling the currency
and high oil prices which eventually crashed.
So by the time
Chavez died
his vice president,
Nicolas Maduro
inherited an economy
in a lot of trouble.
Then 2018 happened.
Maduro said he won
the presidential race.
But the opposition and a lot of countries disagreed.
So the opposition basically said the presidency is vacant
and according to
the constitution
the president of the parliament should take over
and call new elections.
That man was Juan Guaido.
So for the last two years
both men have laid claim
to the presidency.
Most opposition parties
consider Guaido to be the acting president.
He’s also recognised by
nearly 60 countries
including most of Latin America, the US and the EU.
And then there’s Maduro
who has the backing
of countries
like Russia and China.
And he’s the real authority
on the ground.
He has the loyalty
of the military
the national guard and
a civilian militia.
Military officials also
control industries like
the state oil company
and Maduro’s appointees
run institutions like
the Supreme Court.
And even though
the government
is nearly bankrupt
Venezuela still manages
to trade with
allies like Turkey and Iran.
Guaido just can’t access those kinds of resources.
But he does have
public support.
Just not as much as before.
In 2019 hundreds of
thousands of people
rallied for months,
backing Guaido.
And after nearly 50
people were killed
mostly by security forces
momentum fizzled out.
Guaido’s coalition of opposition parties then tried
other ways to put
pressure on Maduro.
And they had help
from abroad.
Sanctions have blocked Venezuelan oil exports.
Government assets worth billions of dollars
have been frozen, including Venezuelan gold
in the Bank of England.
Mercenaries have even tried
and failed
to overthrow Maduro.
But after all that Maduro
is still around.
And his supporters say what the opposition has been doing
is evidence of an international conspiracy to remove Maduro.
And here’s another thing.
Maduro is pretty unpopular.
His disapproval rating according to one pollster
is 77%.
But Guaido’s isn’t far behind.
And now there are parliamentary elections.
Maduro says more
than 100 parties
have candidates running
and he’s invited
foreign observers.
But Guaido and some of the main opposition parties
say the elections have been rigged from the start.
Opposition leaders have been jailed or simply removed
and several political parties have been banned.
They also say the body that runs elections is made up of
people appointed by the pro-Maduro Supreme Court.
So instead Guaido and the main opposition parties
are doing their own thing.
They’re calling on
people to boycott
the election in December.
And in the meantime they’re holding their own referendum.
It’s to ask people if they approve of what Maduro’s
doing and if they
want him gone.
But some just
aren't convinced.
They say it’s better to run and try to win a seat in parliament.
Either way Maduro
stands to win
control of basically everything.
And people who
want change
haven’t been protesting
the way they used to.
They’re in the middle
of a pandemic.
There’s a state of emergency.
There’s also a lot of fear.
So the protests may be smaller but the anger is growing.
A lot of people also seem
to have just given up.
Many have lost faith in politicians, protests
and elections.
Whether Juan Guaido can convince people to boycott
the vote and take part
in his referendum
may give us an idea of just how much hope
is actually left.
And while you’re here make sure to subscribe, like
or follow Al Jazeera wherever you’re watching this video
to stay on top of
world news.
And I’ll see you
next week.